is it still a golden age of Television
we'll leave that for the critics to
decide but one thing we do know is that
there's some tarnish on that shine these
shows are premiered in 2022 prove it
there's no shortage of crime dramas on
television so the end game already faced
an uphill struggle to establish itself
created by former prison break and Law
and Order writer Nicholas Woodson and
arrow producer Jack Coburn the series
saw a thief named Elena federova pull
off a series of audacious heists around
the country while FBI special agent Val
Turner tried to stop her the consensus
among critics was almost universally bad
many complained about the unrealistic
way that the criminal mastermind escaped
from every situation a common enough
occurrence of variety's Caroline fromker
grew borderves after just two episodes I
have a little story to tell you a fairy
tale The Hollywood Reporter suggested
that there was little substance to the
series and the performances of the
normally reliable main cast were
disappointing osmo believe the ends game
did nothing to justify its own existence
and there was little surprise when NBC
canceled it after a single season
reality TV keeps getting weirder it
almost has to because there's so much
competition for eyeballs but adults
adopting adults is a strange concept
even through that lens a group of fully
grown men and women attempt to get other
adults to legally adopt them this is
problematic for a number of reasons
especially because as a guardian
explains adult adoption is a
logistically and emotionally complex
process that varies greatly depending on
location the a E Series almost
immediately attracted criticism one of
the show's most controversial figures
was Danny Huff who tried to adopt a
young woman from Austria best prompted
allegations that he was human
trafficking the potential adoptee
especially when it was made clear that
he had developed romantic feelings for
another 18 year old under similar
circumstances originally scheduled for
10 episodes in total only three aired
before the show was pulled The Daily
Beast called it a Bonkers and creepy
reality show a calling follows police
detective avraham avraham as he puts his
has faced a good use while solving
crimes in New York City all eight
episodes of the first season were made
available on peacock in November it
turned the Rotten Tomatoes approval
rating of just 25 the calling does
little to add anything to the police
procedural genre the religious angle
feels tacked on and it wastes this
opportunity to explore deeper
philosophical themes Town who teaches us
see a single human being
as the whole world Roger eberts.com
saves detective avraham spiritual
musings really don't mean much the
series ended up leaving most reviewers
such as those at Slants magazine feeling
as if it had failed to capitalize on an
interesting premise The Time Traveler's
Wife came with a good pedigree it was
created by Stephen Moffat The Man Behind
Sherlock and several seasons of Doctor
Who it also Stars Game of Thrones alumna
Rose Leslie and White Lotus star Theo
James as a couple who have to deal with
James unexpectedly traveling through
time meaning that they meet out of
sequence so viewers approached it with
high expectations a series based on the
novel by Audrey niffenegger attempts to
address some high concept philosophical
questions about Free Will and control
but critics said it largely failed to
examine those ideas in an effective way
and its plot lines become confusing far
too quickly TV inside equipped if only
time travel were real they could use it
to go back and do it right The Hollywood
Reporter meanwhile criticize a lack of
Chemistry Between the two leads as well
as a constantly changing tone Fairview
is an animated sitcom from the creative
minds of RJ freed and Stephen Colbert
it's hit Comedy Central in early 2022.
what was meant to be a satirical look at
small town drama and politics in America
turned into a complete disaster made
worse by the fact that Colbert's
involvement had given people some hope
almost certainly meant to appeal to the
same crowd that watches South Park this
show is little more than a rip-off of
the cruelly drawn cartoon but the show's
biggest sin is that it just isn't funny
the daily beasts confirm that there is
really only one joke in Fairview about
idiots who don't care about their own
safety critic Nick Shaker wrote is free
play with a particularly off-putting
brand of brash cheery screechiness what
do you say it Kelly ready to throw the
most banging negligent homicide this
town's ever seen the series failed to
capture the hearts and minds of
audiences TV series finale noted as
consistently low ratings throughout its
age episode run those few viewers who
did watch were unimpressed Fairview has
remarkably low approval scores from
users on IMDb and Rotten Tomatoes the
21st century has seen a huge rise in
musical television series whether it's
High School Musical and Glee or the more
adult-oriented galavants and crazy
ex-girlfriend so it makes sense that
folks would try another one Monarch
follows the lives of the Roman family a
dynasty of confit musicians who are
doing everything they can to stay on top
of the charts deadline knows that the
series actually had a promising start
but failed to maintain its viewership or
quality over the course of the first
season that decline along with a poor
critical reception gave Fox all the
reason it needed to cancel the show with
an approval rating of just 31 on Rotten
Tomatoes few reviews had anything
positive to say about the musical series
many of the complaints focused on
Susan's saradon's disappointingly small
role with The Hollywood Reporter writing
there's no breakout character to be
found in Monarch and no breakout
performances the terminal lists have
plenty going for it the action thriller
series had several high profile names
attached including Chris Pratt Constance
Wu and Taylor Kitsch and it follows the
story of a Navy SEAL trying to keep his
family safe while he investigates the
deaths of many of his colleagues in an
ambush that cast and premise seems like
the formula for a top-notch watch but
critics labeled the show boring TV line
found almost every aspect of the show
mundane calling the action sequences an
exciting and adding we get Saturn family
scenes and a pain by numbers conspiracy
that gets more complicated but not any
more compelling some including Jack Carr
the author of the novels that the show
is based on believes that the negative
reviews for the results of political
bias both critics almost universally
agreed the show was confusing and
unsatisfying TV Guide knows that Amazon
Prime members watch the heck out of it
though so there will surely be a second
season
[Music]